[Music]
draped in the blue and yellow of ukraine
the european parliament heard president
vladimir zelinski's emotional plea for
his country to join the eu
the european union is going to be much
stronger with us he said without you
ukraine is going to be all alone
it's clear the west is on his side the
eu voted overwhelmingly to accept
ukraine's application for membership we
will overcome and we will prevail we are
united and we stay united
while in geneva delegates to the un
human rights commission walked out on
russia's foreign minister leaving him to
address an empty room minister lavrov
was being broadcasted
giving his version
which is false about what is happening
in ukraine
in a further act of isolation the u.s
now believes russia should lose its seat
at the table with the human rights
commission other nations have suggested
expelling russia from the u.n security
council if president putin succeeds in
his stated goal of toppling ukraine's
democratically elected government
the human rights and humanitarian crises
will only get worse
all the while nato's forces continue
their buildup and training on its
eastern flank as commitments for western
sanctions and military and humanitarian
aid continue to grow
yet solidarity also extends to the firm
limits of western resolve a nato
enforced no-fly zone remains unlikely
plans to provide ukraine with fighter
jets are no longer on the table
both measures seen as too risky for nato
forces tonight the world will be
watching washington closely as president
joe biden delivers his first state of
the union address the speech is likely
to send strong signals about how far the
u.s is willing to go for ukraine in one
unmistakable sign the first lady's guest
of honor is ukraine's ambassador to the
u.s
donna all right jackson in washington
thanks